la guerre en ukraine pour commencer avec
du nouveau dans le donbass d'après les
autorités locales les russes contrôlent
entièrement ce mardi le village de
touche deux touches kiffca sur la ligne
de front par ailleurs les combats sont
toujours en cours dans la zone
industrielle de severodonetsk là où sont
repliés les derniers combattants
ukrainien à la situation est très
compliquée aussi dans la ville voisine
de l'iscid chances que la tension qui
est aussi monté brusquement d'un cran à
kaliningrad cette enclave où vivent un
million de russes on va peut-être voir
la carte kelly grade est situé entre la
lituanie et la pologne donc en plein
coeur de l'europe et comme la russie aux
continental et bien elle est frappée par
les sanctions européennes
vilnius bloquent depuis ce matin le
transit par voie ferrée de certaines
marchandises et moscou dénonce un blocus
et menaces il faut s'attendre à des
conséquences sérieuses pour la lituanie
gauthier rybinski on va s'y arrêter avec
vous bonjour bonjour c'est tensions
autour de kaliningrad elles sont très
sérieuses en elles sont très sérieuses
parce que vous l'avez dit ça correspond
alors plutôt à une ex clave russe au
sein de l'union européenne
et si on va voir une carte vous avez
lyon on vous voit une carte donc il faut
le faire vous avez raison ce qui permet
de dire que finalement l'ex clave de
kaliningrad et l'histoire en gros de la
prusse orientale la voici la voilà donc
vous voyez s'est exclamée la voix si
elle correspond à ce qui était autrefois
la prusse orientale
c'est à dire une région qui a connu
historiquement beaucoup de brassage mais
qui était surtout quand même
germanophone pour signaler la chose pour
l'anecdote immanuel quand le jeune
philosophe allemand était originaire de
königsberg donc c'est le nom allemand
qu'est ce qui se passe après la guerre
de 1914 iem guerre mondiale l'union
soviétique conquiert en poussant vers
l'ouest puisque elle s'arrêtera à l'elbe
un peu plus loin voilà tout au fond elle
conquiert cette région et la déclare
donc comme faisant partie de la
république fédérative socialiste de
russie le problème c'est que avec la
modification des frontières la pologne
se retrouve là puisque la pologne en
quelque sorte une translation en perdant
des territoires à l'ouest et en gagnant
à l'ouest et puis vous avez alors à
l'époque ça n'est pas problématique
la lituanie la lettonie et l'estonie qui
se trouve voilà tout à fait là haut et
qui sont partie prenante ou partie
intégrante de l'union soviétique à
partir de là quel est le problème à
partir du moment où il ya indépendance
des trois pays baltes et de la pologne
qui s'émancipe du bloc soviétique tout
cela devenant membre de l'otan et
l'union européenne bien c'est
l'approvisionnement l'approvisionnement
entre la russie par drew ici continental
est l'ex clave de kaliningrad et qu'est
ce qu'on a trouvé on n'a pas trouvé
mieux que de passer par la biélorussie
qui est ami de la russie et avec ce
corridor ici qu'on appelle corridor de
suu kyi qui rejoint qui est le point le
plus court finalement entre la
biélorussie et kaliningrad et qui permet
à l'ex clave de kaliningrad d'être en
liaison avec la russie est également
donc qui peut permettre d'exporter ou
d'importer des marchands kagan juste le
corridor il passe par quelques élèves du
corridor et gers à la frontière entre la
pologne et la lituanie qu'il fasse par
la pologne la lituanie les îles et sur
la sur la planche si j'ose dire et il
rejoint donc cet ex club de kaliningrad
à cette région de la biélorussie qui
permet ensuite de continuer vers la
russie caisse de quoi s'agit-il
aujourd'hui il s'agit de bloquer les
marchandises non pas les passagers parce
qu'il ya un trafic assez important vous
l'avais dit il ya un million de russes
qui vivent dans l'ex clave est à peu
près une centaine de trains par année
qui circulent entre ses 7 ex clave entre
kaliningrad et la russie deuxièmement la
russie paul possède dans cette ex l'a vu
une flotte importante qui sont seuls
accès à la mer baltique
donc on voit qu'il y à là pour la russie
a qu'un éventuel casus belli d'autant
qu' elle n'a jamais digéré la russie
l'indépendance de ces trois pays baltes
qu'elle considère comme étant partie
intégrante de son territoire alors que
culturellement et linguistiquement elles
sont bien séparés puis surtout elles
appartiennent à l'union européenne et
année à l'otan la lituanie la est en
première ligne au fond elle ne fait
qu'appliquer les sanctions européennes
c'est quoi sa position la lituanie a une
position extrêmement dures contre la
russie parce que elle craint pour elle
même et puis elle considère que ce que
comme et la russie en ukraine et
évidemment impardonnable excusable
injustifiable et contrairement aux pays
européens aux pays européens de l'ouest
elle est beaucoup plus sévères comme
d'ailleurs la pologne et les autres pays
baltes et plus sévères vis-à-vis de la
russie en disant nous nous connaissons
nous savons ce que c'est que
l'oppression russe ou soviétique et on
vous garantit que la chose est possible
dans ce petit pays attention qu'avait
dit jens stoltenberg secrétaire général
de l'otan il avait dit si la moindre
flammèches si la moindre balle si la
moindre si le moindre au but sabah en
territoire de l'otan et bien nous
riposterons parce que c'est l'article 5
de l'otan assistance militaire à un pays
de l'otan qui est agressé situation à
surveiller de très près donc merci
beaucoup gauthier pour ses explications